الوضع الان في القياده العسكريه الروسيه
للعمليات سيكون تحت امراض فالري جراسيموف
قائدا لها فيما سيتولى الجنرالات سرج
سورفيكين واوليج سيليكونوف والكسيكيم
مساعته لكن نعود مره اخرى الى اسم
سورفيكين هذا القائد السابق للعمليات الذي
عين في اكتوبر الماضي لاصلاح وضع الجيش
الروسي الذي تكبد انتكاسات في منطقه
سورفيكين انسحاب القوات الروسيه من مدينه
خيرسون في مطلع نوفمبر والذي وصف بانه
نكسه كبيره
هذه المده الزمنيه القصيره سلطه الضوء على
تناقضا تناقض لحلفاء الرئيس افلامير بوتن
مع بعضهم البعض بشان التقدم في ساحه
المعركه وهو ما هو وثقته صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز عبر شهادات من خبراء ومدوني حرب
موالينا للكرامنج اكدوا فيها ان التغيير
بعيد كل البعد عن الاصلاح الجذري الذي
يحتاجه الجيش الروسي ليصبح اكثر فعليا
التقرير افاد بان التغيير اظهره ان بوتن
مازال يركز على الحفاظ على توازن القوى
بين الحلفاء الرئيسيين بدلا من تصحيح
العيوب الاساسيه للجيش ليبقى السؤال الاهم
هل سيكون القائد الجديد فالريج راسي موف
كسابقيه والمساله مجرد تغيير اسماء دون
خططه جواهر
[موسيقى]
صحيفه التلغراف اهتمت بموضوع التغيير
السريع للقيادات العسكريه الروسيه
والسعاده بخبراء لتحليل ما يسميه الغرب
مبدا برسم الذي يرى ان الانتصار في الحروب
لا يتم في ساحه المعركه فقط بلبل حرب
السيبراني ايضا الا انا العديد من الاسئله
التي يواجهها بوتن في الحرب ستبقى عالقه
رغم تغيير القيادات حسب الصحيفه
فالجينرالات الروس لا يستطيعون التغيير
قواعد اللعبه او اسكات المنتقدين بمن فيهم
رئيس مجموعه فاجنر
الذي تتصاعد دعواته لمحاسبه المسؤولين عن
تعثر الجيش في عمليته خلال العام باكرانيا
تاتي هذه التطورات فيما يدور الحديث في
اروقه الاستخبارات الغربيه عن تعبئه جديده
في روسيا
مخاوف اعلان موجه جديده لتعبئه في روسيا
لا تزال قائمه بين الشباب الروسي على
الرغم من تعبئه 320,000 جنديا روسي خلال
الموجه الاولى وسط تقارير اعلاميه وغربيه
تتحدث عن امكانيه بدء عمليه التعبئه بعد
انتهاء اعياد راس السنه في روسيا وفي ظل
عدم وجود ضمانات لعدم اعلانها بسبب عدم
توقيع الرئيس الروسي على رسوم ينهيها اما
الكرنب اكد على عدم صحتها هذه الشائعات
وشدد على ضروره الاستماع فقط الى
التصريحات الرسميه وفي ظل خطط وزير الدفاع
الروسيس الجيش ارجوك زياده حجم الجيش الى
مليون و500 شخص تحدث رئيس لجنه الدفاع في
جسدومه عن امكانيه زياده سن التجنيد في
روسيا الى 30 عاما